ملكة جمال الكون الجديدة
هي
جنوب إفريقيا ،
شكرًا لك على مسيرتك الأولى ملكة جمال
الكون
2019. لقد
نشأت في عالم حيث امرأة
تشبهني
بنوع بشرتي وشعري لم يُنظر إليه أبدًا
على أنه
جميل وأعتقد  لقد حان الوقت لأن
يتوقف هذا اليوم ،
أريد أن ينظر الأطفال
إلي ويرون وجهي وأريدهم أن يروا
وجوههم
تنعكس في وجهي ، شكرًا لك ،
أعتقد أنه ثوري ، ملكة جمال
الكون تبحث عن قائدة
ولكن تريد أن تكون أكثر  مثلهم
كمدافعة عن الصحة العقلية والعاطفية ،
أريد تعليم الفتيات أنه من خلال
مسابقة ملكة الجمال ،
لا يوجد شيء لا يمكن للجمال أن
يمنعه من
التواجد على مسرح ملكة جمال الكون
ليس مجرد حلم
أعتقد أنني وجدت مهمتي إنها
تمثيل التفاني
والمرونة والمثابرة
أعتقد أن مهمتي هي أن أظهر
للعالم أن السحر يحدث عندما نرفض
الاستسلام لأن الكون يستمع دائمًا
إلى قلب عنيد